- Hi, everyone, I'm Maurice Samuels,
the director of the Yale Program
for the study of Anti-Semitism,
and along with my colleague, Carolyn Dean,
we wanna welcome you here today.
It's an especially, excuse me, great honor
to introduce today's speaker, Philip Nord.
He's the Rosengarten Professor of Modern
and Contemporary History at Princeton,
where he's taught since 1981.
One of the leading historians of late 19th
and 20th century France, excuse me.
He's devoted his career
to exploring the working
of ideologies like
anti-Semitism and republicanism,
and how they shape cultural forms.
Excuse me.
His books include,
"Paris Shopkeepers and the
Politics of Resentment," 1986,
"The Republican Moment:
Struggles for Democracy
in 19th Century France," 1995,
"Impressionists and
Politics: Art and Democracy
in the 19th Century,"
2000, "France's New Deal:
From the '30s to the Postwar Era," 2010,
and his new book, which
we'll be talking about today.
After the Deportation: Memory
Battles in Postwar France,"
which was just published by
Cambridge University Press
and is the subject of a
round table on H-Diplo
that Carolyn edited.
And I'll just say that
this book is stunning,
in both its breadth and its depth.
As I said in my review
for that round table,
it's gonna be the definitive
history of the way
that World War II was
remembered in France.
Philip Nord is a Guggenheim
fellow, a former director
of the Shelby Cullom Davis Center
for Historical Studies at Princeton,
and the recipient of
many awards and honors.
He also happens to be a fellow Chicagoan.
And so now let me just say a word
about how things will work today.
First, Phil will present the book,
then Carolyn is gonna
say a few words about it,
then we'll open it up to your questions
and we'll finish promptly at 6:00 p.m.
So please submit your questions
using the Q&A function
at the bottom of your screen.
And I will ask them to Phil.
Please don't raise your
hands since we won't see you.
You're welcome to start
submitting questions at any time,
including during the lecture itself.
And now I will hand it over
to professor Philip Nord.
- Thank you, Maury.
So greetings to the
audience whom I can't see,
but I'm hopeful, if not
confident that you're out there.
Let me begin by expressing
some words of thanks
to Maurice Samuels and Carolyn Dean
for organizing this event.
And also a word also for Alice Kaplan,
who was supposed to
participate but has been ill.
And so I'd like to wish her well.
So let me begin with a
few introductory remarks,
before we turn to the discussion.
About 160,000 French people
were deported from France
during World War II to Nazi camps
in Central and Eastern Europe.
76,000 of these deportees were Jews.
And for Jews deportation in effect
meant a sentence of death.
Very few returned, a couple
thousand, a little bit more.
But almost everybody who
was deported was murdered.
For the others, many of these
were resistance fighters
and their chances of
dying were high as well,
a little under 50%.
So there are two very
different experiences
as these mortality rates
attest of what the deportation
experience was like and yet in French,
both experiences are
subsumed under a common term,
la déportation, the deportation.
Immediately at the end of the war,
stories started to be told
about this experience.
They were told in a variety of formats,
through a variety of
means and vehicles, books,
poetry, movies, artwork,
monuments, memorials of all kinds.
This right from the very start.
And the people who told these
stories, fashioned them,
came from a variety of backgrounds.
Some were survivors, some
are relatives of survivors,
some were artists who thought
the experience urgent enough
that they felt they had to deal with it
in one way or another.
And I discuss a number
of these in my books
and I'll cite you a list,
it's longer than that,
but some of the principle
ones, Robert Antelme,
Pablo Picasso, I'll I Renee, John Keyhole,
David Ruse, Elie Wiesel,
Andre Schwarz-Bart,
Claude Longspawn and others as well
whom I will mention in my
remarks as we go along.
So many media, many people,
it's an enormous outpouring.
I wind down my analysis
of this corpus of work
sometimes in the mid 1990s,
but it continues on that down
to the present days and
I'm still reading it.
And I suspect I will be reading
it for many years to come.
These stories are patterned
by political and religious commitments.
The communists who were among the first
to get into the story
telling practice or game,
I don't wanna use that word,
get into the practice of storytelling,
told a story of anti-fascist struggle.
The non-communist left also entered
the frayed not long thereafter
and for them the concentration airy form
was not the open urge of
the fascist world alone,
but of totalitarians and generals,
Stalins as well as Hitler instead
had concentration camps.
For others, the concentration
reform was something
that was imminent in modern life itself.
And you found it everywhere,
not just in in Hitler's Germany
or Stalin's Soviet union,
but you found that even in France itself,
France maintaining interment
concentration camps
during the Algerian war.
The galst also had a word to
say about camps and deportation
but they saw it through the
lens of an ongoing struggle
against a hereditary full Germany
and discussed this
experience in the framework
of what they called the 30 years war.
Now, as for religious commitments,
Roman Catholic deportees
talked about their experience
as the fight of the spirit
against the Nazi new paganism,
and Jews too had something
to say about the deportation
experience really
from the right from the very beginning.
It was seen in a variety of lights.
And these first post-war decades
as part of a a millennial long experience
of persecution that dated
back to biblical times.
And from this perspective,
those who were murdered
in the deportation, murdered in the camps,
had died as martyrs in
sanctification of the name.
Kidush Hasham.
But others stressed Jewish resistance
in the face of Nazi persecution.
Aside in the case of the
Warsaw ghetto uprising,
but not just that, there were
also sonderkommando revolts
in various death camps at
Chelmno, Sobibor and Treblinka.
And these two were celebrated,
and these Jewish death
were understood to be not just martyrs,
but also humans.
So there is an ebb and flow to the stories
told about the deportation,
a variety of themes and
narratives interweaving.
Try to make four points about these,
about this ebb and flow.
One is it's inflicted by events.
The major events of
the year, the cold war,
of course the Algerian war
which I've already mentioned.
But also the work of 1967,
the Arab Israeli war,
but the negation is crisis
the 1980s and 1990s.
And I should add as well,
the De Gaulle's return to power in 1958.
But, Jews were always a part of the story.
It used to be received wisdom
that there was a long silence.
And of course in many
homes and many families,
that's true but I'm talking
about a public science.
It used to be thought that
there was a public science
in the science and the Jewish
experience in Jewish suffering
was not not discussed.
And I try to push back
against this a little bit
acknowledging isn't
the first word decades,
while there was a Jewish voice,
there were many many other
voices that were much loud
and occupied more space
in the public domain.
All these voices, not quite a cacophony,
but sometimes they
contended with each other,
competed with each other, and
fought against each other.
And the communist scholars struggle
over deportation memories perhaps
the most the most well-known.
And that's why I put memory
battles in the title of my book
because where there was cooperation,
there was also contention.
Now the Jewish voice would grow stronger
in the 1970s and 1980s,
and eventually become,
or the 1990s, the dominant one.
And as a result, historians
talk about a reversal of memory.
And as I see it, it's not just
that the Jewish voice becomes dominant,
but also the tonality of
the Jewish story itself
begins to change with
the focus less on heroism
and on modernism and more
on the experience of loss.
The emphasis is no longer
on sacrifice, more on loss,
and sometimes also on victimization.
All of these of course begs the question
as to why such a reversal
of memories took place.
The answer to this and
others have addressed it,
the question, my answer
is a little different.
Often the practice is to emphasize
very particular about the
Eichmann trial of 1961.
Which was sort of turned a light
on in public consciousness.
Or the Arab Israeli war
of 1867, 1967 forgive me.
And I do treat these events,
but I interpret them
less as turning points
than as the accelerators
pushing a process forward
that had its origins in elsewhere
with other kinds of explanations.
And I insist on two vectors
of change in particular,
the first, once again not unique to me
but I put a lot of weight on
it is Catholic Jewish dialogue,
Christian Jewish dialogue,
Catholic in particular.
So, Catholics play a
prominent role in my story
of two kinds, one is
brokers or intermediaries
as possible who helped
bring the Jewish story
to public attention.
And here I would cite
the case of Jack Maritan
who was a very good
friend of Marc Chagall's.
Collected some of Chagall's work,
or Frostmot Mobiack who
provided the introduction
to Elie Wiesel's (speaking
foreign language)
when it was published
in French in 1958.
And also lesser known for
you, a man named Paul Flamo,
who was the editor at Lesoi.
But Lesoi was the publishing house
that first published
Andre Schrafft's Butt's
(speaking in foreign language)
in 1959, which was a
pre gold corp winning.
A very prestigious prize,
Plumber published Elie
Wiesel after one week.
And he was also the publisher of some of
Saul Friedlander's first works.
And some of you in the audience
who will know Saul Friedlander's
spectacular work on the Holocaust,
the recent to value study.
But it wasn't all about dialogue.
There was also a lot of contention
between Christians and Jews,
between Catholics and Jews.
And this to royal the public domain.
And this connection I
would cite three things.
First of all, the work of Julie Zack,
some of you may know, wrote
a groundbreaking hefty texts
which was published in late 40s.
Jay Xu in Israel, he excoriates the church
for what he calls the
teaching of contempt.
The teaching of anti-Semitism
across millennia,
the teaching bit in Isaac's
polemic grease the wheels
that led train loads of Jews to Auschwitz
Not just Isaac,
there's also the family
affair, which erupted
in public life in 1952 and 1953.
I don't wanna rehearse it in detail,
but two Jewish boys had been placed
for safekeeping during
the war, by their parents
with a Catholic religious order.
The parents were deported and murdered.
The children survived,
looked after by this religious order
who farmed them out to a nurse.
And after the war, an aunt
came looking for them,
and the caretaker had
the children baptized
and the church did not want
to let go of the children
in effect kidnapping them.
And there was a major, major public uproar
that was not just
national but international
at the same time.
Very contentious, in the
end the boys were released
to their aunt and the family, the remnants
of the (indistinct)
family moved to Israel.
I treat this as a scene setter
for the Catholic churches,
Vatican too reflections on
its teaching on the Jews,
and at Vatican too.
It people a declaration follows,
called no strike a tattoo
in our times, which represents a beginning
of rethinking church
doctrine on Jewish life.
But the Catholic Jewish
dialogue plays a major role
in my discussion.
And so too does 1968, I
understand 1968 batches the events
of Bay, of that year in France,
but as a longer phenomenon,
what historians called the long 68
because somewhere in the mid 1960s
and stretches on into
the it at the beginning
of the meta run presidency
in the early 1980s.
And to me, 68 understood in this way
as meaningful in my story in three ways.
First of all, a number of the
principles worked 68 hours.
Marcello Fools was active in it,
strike at public television in 1968.
And some of you will know
who Marcello Fools was, made a couple
of quite spectacular movies
having to do with the wartime experience,
the (indistinct) which
he completed in '69,
and showed not on TV, but
in movie theaters in 1971.
Later in 1976 another
movie called the movement,
memory of justice was deals
not just with the war,
but also with Francis Algerian war,
and with the American war in Vietnam
pushing them all together and
inviting people to reflect
about the connections between
these kinds of experiences.
Or, I could mention Beata Clarksville.
And once again, most of you
will know who the Clarksville
work Biatta and Sarah, and
she was involved in strikes
in 1968 in France.
So there were 68s involved in the story.
And as all Fools movies demonstrate
what they were doing with their artwork
was in part how should I put it,
busting myths about world war II.
Particularly Gallston and communist ones.
And in effect, debunking received wisdom
on what the war had been all about
in effect clearing the memory decks
so that other kinds of
stories, not common,
it's not common, not goals,
but other kinds of stories,
Jewish in particular could surge
into the public consciousness.
And a third way in which 68 played a role
has to do with techniques.
And here Biatta Clarksville
is a good case of point,
Biatta and Sage, both
who did scholarly work,
but also who were past masters
and publicizing events.
Orchestrating courtroom dramas,
taking part in demonstrations,
sit ins, all to force on the public
a consciousness of what
had happened to the Jews
during the second world war.
Now the last substantive
chapter of my book
deals with cold last man's show up.
And I wind up there for
a variety of reasons.
I suppose one of them is
that it's a monumental work,
and monuments figure very prominently
in most of the chapters of my book.
There is a communist corner,
or parallel says cemetery
in Northeastern Paris
where there was a whole host
of concentration camp memorials.
I should also mention that the Memorial,
(speaking foreign language)
and some of you who have visited it,
it's located just behind Notre dame.
Maybe not easy to access these days.
There is the concentration camp and world
in France itself that
struck off in Alsace.
A memorial at la Shoah it's
now known in the Moraine
which is a Jewish Memorial when
it was first opened in 1956
it was known by another
name is the Tom bow do motto
which we found canoes.
The tomb of the unknown
Jewish martyr changed his name
to the Memorial (indistinct)
unknown Jewish martyr
to (speaking foreign language).
So I discussed memorials
throughout monuments,
throughout, and last month's work
is monumental and over
nine hours in length.
Also, it gives a new name
to the experience of Jewish deportation.
In France, The Holocaust is used,
but not as currently as the word Shoah,
it's a strange word from
the Hebrew, not well known.
But it catches something, something.
And this is the third
reason why it ended up
of the singularity and
unprecedented nature
of the Holocaust, unprecedented scales,
and its means of execution.
And, last man's movie exemplifies as well
this new understanding
of what the show war was.
Not a story of heroism or even of martyrs,
but a story of unredeemed loss.
And in this connection
to figures in the movie
who stand out for me and I
suspect for others as well,
are the sonderkommandos.
Those who were charged with
disposing of the bodies
of the murdered people.
Now people like Philip
Mueller and Abraham Bombay,
who both figure prominently
as interviewees in last months movie.
And they were Sonderkommandos
who had literally
entered into the gas chambers
and come out again alive
and could tell about as much
as any living human being
about what that experience was.
And then of course, the
figure of Simon Srebotnik,
who was sonderkommando at Chelmno,
charged with burning bodies.
And it's with him that Langsman
opens the movie and closes.
I conclude, I have a conclusion
epilogue, and a conclusion.
With some reflections about
why this outpouring soul
inventive in its nature
happened in France, why they are
and not say in Israel
or the United States.
Not that it was ignored in
Israel, the United States
but it is unusually creative
from the French and the French context.
And I propose three kinds
of explanations for that.
First one is, is if I were to hesitate
use his demographic,
but it's a way of saying
that one, there were a
lot of Jews in France
after the war the Jewish
community is about a quarter
of a million strong.
Yes, I think 78, 79,000
choose total were murdered
of the French Jewish community,
but three quarters of
the community survived
in hiding or in exile.
And then they return after the war.
So there was a Jewish population
that hadn't experienced
persecution in France itself,
numerous and willing to speak.
In addition to that,
they were all the racy stone
deportees who came back
tens of thousands of them with
stories of their own to tell.
So there was a community varied
in nature that had an interest
in wanting to talk about
the deportation experience.
Not just that, there are political reasons
why this mattered so much in France.
France had suffered defeat
in 1940 and occupation.
There after, experiences of humiliation,
and there were racy stomp
but also deportees whose
sacrifice could be understood
as something redemptive.
So that the story of the war
was not just a story
of humiliation defeat,
but a horror of a story of resistance
and redemptive sacrifice at the same time.
And the question is who would
own this particular memory?
It came freighted with
a lot of moral authority
and many many currents of
opinion wanted to control it.
And there was contention
over their control.
And last of all, my
interlocutors are all experts
on this greater experts than I am.
And it would be true if we added
Alice Kaplan into the group.
The post-war decades in France are periods
of exceptional creativity
and deportation literature intersects
with these currents of creativity.
With surrealism and existentialism,
with modernist architecture,
with new wave cinema,
with the new novel, with
ULI Paul, which is the
(speaking foreign language)
I don't know how to translate that.
But in any case it's a literary movement
that George Prereq belonged to.
And he writes about the deportation
and W Souvenir doll falls.
And when it comes to movies,
the intersection between
cutting edge cinema and the
deportation is complete.
And I just mentioned once again,
Rene and Keyholes movie night and fog,
but not just that, Marcello
Fool, Lancemans Shoah,
and there are more
(speaking foreign language)
which is 1961 kind of lesser known movie
called (speaking foreign
language) from 1961.
Also, these are all very creative
imaginative management works.
So it's my hope that
people who read the book,
even if they don't agree
with anything I have to say
will at least find it worthwhile to visit
or revisit the works that I discussed
in the book of the monuments,
the artwork, the novels.
Because it is a creative
Corpus and quite wonderful,
that deserves the widest
possible probably.
Thank you very much.
- Thank you Phil for that really
great summary of the book.
So now we'll have a
few words from Carolyn,
and then we will open it up to questions.
So everyone in the audience
please start sending
questions using the Q and A
function at the bottom of your screen
Welcome everyone.
Welcome to professor Philip Nord.
Thank you Maury.
I just wanted to take a few minutes
to clarify the importance
of Philip Nord's new book
partly because as he says,
he pushed back a little bit
on a certain assumption about
the fact that Jews in France
during the immediate post-war
period till 1968 were silent.
Now, he doesn't just push back
on this idea a little bit.
He actually (indistinct) our understanding
of deportation in France.
In fact, this book is, and I
say this with no exaggeration,
the most important discussion
and history of deportation
from Vichy France
of Jews and communist political dissidents
of the past 30 years.
The first important discussion
which really set the stage
was Dienpre book which was
called the Vichy syndrome,
which suggested that
there was this silence
and it had been, and noise,
though there was discussion
among Jews, the noise began
only about the Jewish
deportation and specificity
only at 1968.
Before I sort of discuss this,
say just a little more in
more detail in a minute,
I just wanna know for the audience,
those of you who may or may not know this.
And perhaps Phil would
like to comment on this
after in the question,
the Q and A session.
That the majority of
Jews deported from France
during this period were
in fact foreign Jews
who had fled Nazi or an Austria
since Hitler took power in
1938, I mean, 1933, excuse me.
And of course, and next Austria in 1938.
And they were also those Jews
who'd been naturalized
French, especially since 1927.
It's a very important naturalization law
and many Jews from Eastern
Europe who had lived in France
had been naturalized.
And the French government
under the Vichy regime
undertook a de naturalization process
of many of these Jews, not all of them
who were stripped of their citizenship
and then were allowed to
be in turn by definition.
They were all enemies of the state,
and they were interned in France.
So I thought that was
just an interesting fact
that would be important to mention
because the majority of French Jews,
not all of them of course, did survive.
And that is a question that has raised
that has provoked a lot
of discussion and debate.
And I (indistinct) Phil
wanting to speak to that,
just because it's an
interesting fact about France.
Now, let me just reiterate some things
Phil said very quickly after 1945,
the French imagined deportee
as anti-fascist patriotic
victims of the Nazi regime
that were usually, are
usually cited for this period
and communist accounts of
French heroic martyrdom
focused on resistance fighters,
elected Jewish suffering.
That is the usual narrative
about this period.
It goes on to say
immediately after the war,
the French rarely made
distinctions between death camps
and concentration camps, or
imagine them to be different
for Nazi torture and persecution.
Some people died in death camps,
and some people in concentration camps.
Jews as Phil has noted,
works supposedly silent,
meaning that they spoke to
each of their experiences
but their voices were otherwise inaudible.
So it was all this
narrative goes after 1968,
and the student rebellion,
when this younger generation
questioned French complicity
and also criticized French colonialism.
And these temples (indistinct)
have argued on earth
long repressed memories
about Jewish persecution
and the Vichy regime vetted
until then been buried.
Now, the importance of Phil's book,
it's really a paradigm shattering this
or my characterization
of it in many others
as paradigm shattering, is
because it tells an entirely
different story that is not
just pushing back a little bit.
Other historians of course have suggested
that Jewish voices have
not been entirely silent.
But this book makes a
much more ambitious claim
that Jews were far more central
to the post-war discussions
than it has been imagined.
And in arenas, some of the
ones that Phil mentioned,
camp and war memorials and novels films,
Catholic Jewish dialogue surprisingly,
that we had not thought
to explore previously.
Now he's discussed some
of this for us today
and given us much food for thought.
So I hope we can follow
up with and ask him more
about this important book
in the time remaining.
Thank you Phil.
- Thank you.
Great, Phil, so I don't
know if you had something,
if you wanted to react before we dive in.
If you wanted to react to
Carolyn or add (indistinct).
- Yeah.
So just a few quick reactions.
I wanna give the audience a
chance to have to jump in.
And Carolyn invited me
to say something about
why France has such a
substantial Jewish community
after the war.
It's now, those of you who follow closely
the New York review books can
see the the back and forth
between Robert Paxton and Jackson Mala
over justice issue.
Many Jews survive in France.
And it's Jews in particular
who were deported,
but still a large number of foreign Jews
who've taken refuge in France,
in the interwar decades,
they too survive as well.
And in fact, it's they, even
more than the native born
who will be active in
(speaking foreign language).
Which was one of the first organizations
that pushes a Jewish memory in the 1950s
when there was supposedly silent.
The reasons for Jewish survival,
some of that has to do with geography.
There were mountains.
It helps to have mountains, the Alps.
It helps to have remote
countryside as well.
So what which is why Jews
survival is much less
in small countries like
Belgium or the Netherlands
for that matter.
It also makes a difference
how hard the Nazis tried.
And whether they have the forces on hand
to execute their policy.
And in the East, they tried hard
and they had the Wehrmacht to help out.
And this does not come to pass
in France to the same way,
it's so the level of
murderousness is not the same.
But I don't want to again say
what similar the argument that he makes,
which is that there were many people
to help Jews themselves,
and particular native
born who had resources
and language skills, and could
protect their countrymen,
fellow Jews.
But also non-Jewish French people,
peasants in particular who
welcomed hid Jews in their homes,
but also religious institutions
like Protestant churches.
And some of you well have
heard of (indistinct),
which was a Protestant town,
which was ineffective Vilas refuge,
a place where Jews could go hide
in fairly significant numbers.
But the Catholic church as well
organized networks of rescue.
And in fact,
I've mentioned Saul Friedlaender
and he was protected
and all cachet is called a hidden child
in a Catholic school.
And there are many
other instances of that,
I could go on, but I probably shouldn't.
Yeah, maybe I undersold my
book Carolyn a little bit.
Okay.
I appreciate your doing that.
And then last of all there is
the issue of oppressed memory.
And that's a tricky one, and I'm not sure
that I negotiated it once
again, false modesty on my part,
I negotiated it fully successfully
because there is the puzzle
that if there a lot going on,
why do people talk about repressed memory
and with conviction.
And I guess i say a
number of things to that,
one is that when it comes
to internal life of families
and individuals, there's
plenty of repressed memories.
And so it's just in the public domain
where there are narratives
being annunciated.
That's where there was not the silence,
and maybe these public
stories aren't satisfying
to individual people, and
they don't see themselves
in these public stories
in one way or another.
But also, I try to suggest
that some of the earlier
stories emphasize religion,
heroism, martyrdom, and
that for younger people,
they're not interested
in this kind of thing.
And these are not stories that resonate
with them in any particular way.
And in addition with
France in the mid 1960s,
De Gaulle is back in power and
he is putting the full weight
of the state behind a certain
kind of memory politics
for people who grow up in the
midst of that, in the 60s.
It might seem as though
nothing else existed
but De Gaulles's story.
And maybe some communist story too
if you grew up in a leftist household.
And so at that conjuncture, in that world
it might've seen that there was silence
because other stories were being blurred
so loudly in nature.
And then last of all,
the return of the repressed paradigm
is one that begins to circulate
in the 60s and 70s.
And it's one that's
embraced by young people,
that's why we didn't know about it.
It was repression.
This is how psyche works, this
is how national psyches work
at the same time.
And so that's the kind of explanation,
explanatory framework that I explored.
- Okay, so the Q and A is
blowing up as they say.
So we have a lot of questions.
So one question from an audience member
is whether it just takes
time for, you know,
for emotions to pass to allow for
a more objective non apologetic writing.
So do you discuss that aspect of things,
like maybe people, you
know, it's not just politics
and changing politics,
but also just the fact that
people, you know, couldn't talk,
it took them a while to
be able to talk after...
- Yes.
And there's truth in that.
I think immediately both
Wiesel sketched pieces
of what would become
(speaking foreign language),
and then put it aside.
And Jorge Sendpro did the same thing,
and Charlotte Del Bo did the same thing.
So there absolutely is truth to that.
The only thing I would say is,
while that's also true right
away after the war ends,
deportees begin to appear
in their camp stripes, in
fact, at public events.
And so there was a May day in 1945,
communist deportees are there.
They parade in their stripes,
(speaking foreign language)
in effect.
And the communists,
before the 1940s route are
beginning to build memorials
and paralyzed says cemetery
which are gathering places.
So it may be hard for some
people to talk about individually
but when it comes to
collective memory actions
of the kind of communist undertook
and then the golf pushes back right away,
he retires from public life in 1946
and goes quiet for a little period.
But then people wanna push
back against the communes.
You don't own the deportation story.
There are other stories
that are told here too.
And of course, there are
those like Isaac Schneerson
who was the band behind the say the AJC.
And his view is, you know,
I do not want the people
who were murdered to die
without recognition of
some kind or another.
And I am gonna see that a
monument is built to them.
And he starts this,
he starts during the war in effect.
I mean, he's a very determined figure.
And the Memorial Dulles
Shoah while the first stone
was laid in 1953, and the
building is completed in 1956,
a very very early memorialization.
But so yes, it does require,
I do wanna acknowledge that,
and particularly where
individual memory is concerned.
And some of the people I talk
about have that kind of delay.
But in other instances,
there is no delay at all.
And they begin at laying
down their markers literally
and fighting over this.
And right from 44 or 45.
- So I'm gonna pick up, I'm
gonna jump to a question
because you mentioned the, the
Memorial on the Yielded City
and someone asked a question about that
and about the controversy
about whether it sufficiently
focuses on the Jewishness
of victims.
So could you say a little bit more
about that monument and
the story of your time?
- So it's a quite wonderful monument,
insufficient mention of
the Jews, there is none.
Okay.
I mean, it is alighted completely.
But it's also worth noting
who got the monument built?
And it's three people in particular,
father Michel, Jesuit father a deportee.
Was deported to Dachau
for resistance activities
in a five Semite, but
that's, may not be relevant.
Many And Paula Regi
also a practicing Roman
Catholic and Ed Mommy Schley
also a practicing Roman Catholic.
And the architect that they
got on board to launch this
was among other things.
It was a modernist architect,
but also a church architect.
So I treat this monument as
having a religious inspiration
behind it and behind it initially.
And as they tried to get the
okay to build this moment
for various public authorities,
the public authorities tell them
this is okay but it should
be to the deportation general
and not single anybody out.
So no class, no politics,
no race, no religion.
That's what they're told to do.
And so they tried to
do a big tent Memorial
with a spiritual quality to it.
And I think in it's minimalism,
it has a certain kind of spirituality.
Janet Flanner who was the
New Yorker's woman in Paris
described it as like a wayside shrine.
And it cites texts that
cover the full range.
There are written texts that are
unequipped of this Memorial.
The full range of resistance experience
from father May June all
the way to John Paul Sartre,
and Huriagro.
I think also who's a
communist is also there.
And it takes to build the concrete,
it takes rock from all the
mountain ranges of France.
And so it's meant to be this kind
of encompassing, non-denominational,
but spiritual monument.
And the deal is, no the
Jews get no mention at all
in this particular story.
Although, as I said, father Ricky himself
is not an anti-Semite,
but on the contrary
took risks to save Jews
during the war and was deported.
- Right, yeah.
That's such an interesting monument.
And, you know, we could talk
more about its placement,
but I wanna go to some
of the other questions.
So one from someone who I'm sure you know,
Susan Solomon who writes that,
some historians and other
scholars would choose the Barbie
the Klaus Barbie trial, which
occurred a couple of years
after a long Launce Mon Shoah
as the culminating moment
of the story you're trying to tell,
the memory of the deportation
especially since it led to
a whole slew of new memoirs
by Jewish deportees, as well
as members of the resistance.
So could you say a little bit
more about how you decided
to kind of end your story with Nord.
- Wow, yeah, that's interesting.
How should I put it?
I don't say I downplay the trials.
There's a whole slew of
them that take place,
and they begin in
cologne of Nazi officials
who had been part of the police apparatus
and occupied France.
And then the series of French.
And that was the interest for me
is that is the French
people who participated
in the deportation to
experience it like Paul
or pop hall, Maurice pot for that matter.
And the way in which
this obliged the French,
not just to think the
Germans did bad things to us,
which is easy and which they know.
But then we did bad things ourselves.
It was Vishy that participated in this
and part of the interest for me
and that is that it then draws attention
not just to German spaces,
but to spaces in France
of Jewish suffering.
And that means places like
Drawirsee, the transit camp
in Paris suburbs, or
(indistinct) a children's home
not far from the French Alps,
from which Jewish children
were deported because of Barbie
who was the Leon Gestapo chief.
But so Barbie does figure any
figures in a couple of ways
in this story, one, because
the Klarus Felds go after him
and they track them down to Bolivia
and make a fuss over him
and bring him to the public attention,
also Barbie, because of the easiest story.
Which is one that's particularly touching
because it involves Jewish
children who were murdered.
And so it's part of the story.
I do end with Lanceman in part,
because of the narrative
power of this particular work
and the darkness that it sheds.
Oh, and on the matter
of time, I was thinking,
I'm sorry to revert to an
earlier question cause it...
I think one of the things that just
it takes time to tell the story
but stories build up over time.
So that what is the Holocaust?
Of course its not known in 1944, 1945.
And it requires really decades of work.
That is both scholarly
and testimonial in nature
for the various aspects and
dimensions of this thing,
of this monstrosity to start
to come into focus for people.
So in that sense, this is
another temporal dimension
to the story I have to tell.
- So, we have so many great questions here
and I'm gonna apologize
for not being able to ask all of them.
And I'm just gonna skip to some things
that we haven't touched on but
I think are really important.
So there's a question from
Sam Moen, from our colleague,
about what's at stake in
focusing on writing French
across the genres, versus for instance
some of the early writing in Yiddish,
and speaking in Yiddish
about the deportation.
- So two things, one is
I don't do the Yiddish.
So that is an obstacle.
I got help translating
Elie Wiesel's, Night,
when it first was published in Yiddish
and I was interested in the translation
from French anteaters.
But second of all, and so this isn't just,
I don't have the skills,
it's also I want it
in the domain of putt French public life
and Yiddish is not the linguistic means
by which that will happen.
It has to happen in French.
And so that's why the focus
is on the French language,
the French language corporates.
It's not that I'm not interested
to quite a wonderful book by
a young man named Simo Parago
whom you, I don't know
if you all know him,
but I know Carolyn knows him.
Which is about the Parisian, Jewish world
largely or significantly Yiddish speaking.
And the way in which the
experience in memorialization
and mourning of loss is
present in a very powerful way,
almost in a constitutive
way after World War II.
So if you're interested
in that, there it is.
And he does it beautifully.
But I want it when the
world beyond the borders
to the Jewish community
is made to pay attention,
or is led to pay attention.
And so I think that the
medium for that to happen
is in the French language itself.
- So here's a question from Ron Levy about
how the memory of the
deportation intersects
with other memories,
for instance of Algeria
and the Algerian war.
- So that's a great question.
So this is Michael Rothberg
has written extensively
and inventively, imaginatively about this.
What I would have to add to it
is that some of it depends
on what your politics are.
And so for the non-communist left,
the experience of the Algerian
war is a wake up call.
They are galvanized by this.
Xstore deportees, I mean,
someone like Charlotte Delbelt,
it's a good case in point,
she was once a party member.
She leaves the party, she's
ferociously anti-colonial
and she sees her through the experience,
through the lens of her
own deportation experience
to Auschwitz.
And that fuels her passion.
Now, there are other
people like German Tio
who has been patronized
for whom the Algerian war
is also a crushing experience.
And she wants to find a solution to it.
And she sees the war and torture
through the lens of her own experience,
but she doesn't come out
for an independent Algeria
at the far end.
So in both cases, the war
plays an important role
in mobilizing them,
and their work experience
shapes how they're mobilized.
But they come out at
slightly different places,
just because you intersect,
doesn't mean that you're gonna come out
with the same view of the Algerian war.
Some of that depends on your politics,
and Delvaux is a non-communist
leftist, very left wing.
In German Tiana is a Gaullist.
And so they've come out both
shaped by the Algerian war
and the connection or intersectionality.
That's not the word.
Multidimensionality, that's the word.
Between these two experiences,
but they come out at different places
cause they enter them
politically differently.
- Great, so here's a
question from my colleague
in the French department, Howard Block.
If you could stay more about
the public places of memory,
not the great ones, but
those small signs on
they say and in public gardens.
And especially, I've noticed
also that they've changed
in recent years, and now,
well anyway, I'll let you...
- Actually, I would be interested
in how they've changed.
- I mean, I've noticed that
on schools for instance
there're much more, it
seems like it's a change,
that they're much more willing to say that
it was Jewish children
to mention the Jewishness
of the children who were deported.
Whereas, I feel like when
I used to go to France
like in the first times in the
80s, I don't remember that,
but I could be wrong, so.
- No, and I don't of course
it's one of those things
when do you start looking
and paying attention.
And so my experience is like
yours, like yours Maury.
I think in response to the question,
it's a critique that
is say, I don't do it.
I look at the old you as a,
you know, the high places.
Now, what can I say?
I can have an impression which is
one that these local memorials
are a more recent phenomenon,
but I don't know that for a fact.
It's what I suspect, but I don't know
cause I didn't study it.
The mentioning of Jews,
a good cases is here.
It's not a local, well it's local.
It's now a major national memorial too.
It had right away.
This is the Jewish home,
not far from the French Alps
and Jewish home for children.
And it had a Memorial early on,
but it said nothing about
who the children were.
Now they did have a mug and David on it,
but no mention, no precision after that.
And this changes has
been 1990s completely.
And it's identified both the home itself
and the clap that's on
the home and the monument
which is located some distance away
where they talk about
who the killers were,
who the people who saved children
and who the children were
who died that they were Jewish children.
And so I think that, and a good,
I'll give you another good,
it's not exactly a local,
I'm sorry I'm dodging the question,
but this is more in line
of what you said Maurice.
There's an Auschwitz
rural parish has cemetery,
was erected by communists.
In 1995 the plaque that
you see is added there
that identifies the people
who died at Auschwitz
as being principally Jews.
That's only edited in mid 1990s.
So I have a feeling that
this sort of local story,
and a local story where
Jews are identified by name
is last 30 years story.
A little bit after or where I wind up.
- So here's a really interesting question
about the role of the organized
Jewish community in France,
in controlling memory.
So like the (speaking
in foreign language),
did they try to limit the importance
of the Jewish component of the deportation
out of fear that it
would arouse antisemitism
or that they'd be accused
of communal charisma
and things like that.
- This is, it's an interesting...
I'll tell you what I have on that.
Which was the cost to our
early puts up a plaque
in the (speaking foreign
language) synagogue.
It's in the peristyle there,
which talks about all who were lost,
but it's actually very reticent
about identifying the
people who died as Jews.
Now it's in the synagogue
at the same time.
So it's a little bit hidden away.
And when Isaac Snelson in this
(speaking foreign language)
wants to build a monument
that (indistinct)
has to go in alone.
And he's very creative, very dynamic.
So there's some reticence about that,
but not completely, because the consistoire
does get ashes or soil
from concentration camps
and distributes them around
France for memorial purposes.
It has use career services,
it has Memorial Memorial services.
So while they're low
key and not insistent,
they're not in denial.
And it's an interesting phenomenon,
France has something called
the (speaking foreign language)
every April, a deportation Memorial day.
And there's an itinerary,
various stops along the way.
It was a very smallest shift
fair when it began in 1954
but by 1955, '56, the
Rue de la noir to our synagogue
figured as part of this.
As well as Notre Dame, as
well as Shoah Memorial,
as well as a number of
other memorials as well.
And so even at this early
stage, in the mid 50s we are,
you have the Jewish story
with the call ceased war
included part of the general itinerary
for memorialization of the deportation.
- So we're almost at
the time, but there are
two other questions I
wanna make sure to get to.
So one is, and this is a big question but,
so try to answer it quickly if you can.
But what will the large
immigration of North African Jews
plays in your story?
So, you know, the fact that, you know,
hundreds of thousands of Jews
come because of decolonization
and are now the, you
know, the biggest segment
of the French Jewish population.
- I don't know if you remember
our exchange, Carolyn, Maury.
I got taken to task for these things
and that one too and swag.
I have a feeling got another
sharp audience on our hands.
You know, I really focus
in, and it's a blind spot.
I fear it is.
I mean, I focus on the Ashkenazi community
into the 1960s in the way in which
it's very much transformed
by the arrival of North African Jews
that doesn't figure in my
story and maybe it should.
And then it's something that I've missed
inflexed the story or shapes it,
or rewrites it in surprising way.
I need to be persuaded,
is the way I would put it.
I don't wanna be skeptical,
but it may be more like, I
should be careful what I say.
The way in which the civil
war in the United States
is part of my memory, but I wasn't here.
Had nor were any of my
ancestors when it happened.
And I wondered if it's not the
same thing for smarty Jews.
Of course there are some, I mean,
one of Shearson his right-hand
man is Vidala Modi Yano.
And I write about Modi
Yano's (indistinct),
the novelist Modi Yano's work
and they have sparty background as well.
But they're part of the
story and I don't know
that they have bring a
distinctive something.
- I wonder if you could
argue that they liberated
a certain way of being Jewish and France
and that that enabled the
Ashkenazi's to be more--
- That I don't buy because
the Ashkenazi Schneerson,
he doesn't need anyone to liberate.
- He doesn't need any liberation.
- He's a feisty character in, you know,
ready to put up his dukes, or even Julie.
Zack is a good case in point.
He's a classic native born Jew
who's not particularly
interested in his Judaism,
but an educator interested
in Republican schooling.
But the experience of the
war where he has to go
into hiding, one of his
children is in the resistance,
his wife and daughter are
deported and murdered,
another kid is deported and comes back
and he is full of polemic, and
he's not holding back at all
and he doesn't need an influx of anybody
to help him decide to stand up
for what he sees needs standing up for.
And this in the late 1940s.
So it's not as though, and
he's writing (indistinct)
once again.
He's writing it starting
under the occupation,
while his family is being murdered,
not completing it after the war,
publishing it and then going toe to toe
with Catholic clerics for years on end.
And in fact, it's he's the one,
well I'm doing this, who
talks to John the 23rd
and says, when Vatican II happens,
you have to put this on the dock.
And the Pope says, you know
what, I'm gonna do that.
And he did it.
That's how it got there.
So I don't think it liberates a new...
I mean, it does.
Yes, and it, but I think
that's not part of my story.
- Okay.
I'm noticing, you know, great questions
from Richard Weisberg,
from Katie Trumpeter.
I'm gonna make sure you
see all these questions.
But I don't wanna ask
because we're out of time,
but I wanna ask a last question,
briefly like how the book
has been received in France,
and is it gonna be translated into French?
That was a question from the audience.
- Yeah.
So, I hope so.
Annet Becker is trying to
find a publisher for me.
I suspect I've been published before.
And so actually that's
a plus or minus, right?
If I don't sell, cause
no reason to, you know,
another done for me.
There was more seriousness
to the question than--
- That the reception in France.
Well, you know it's all
been my friends so far.
And, you know, they liked the book.
You know what friends are like.
So I'm hopeful, but I don't know,
I don't know just how it will be.
- Okay, well, we'll see
if we can, you know,
we'll look forward to
hearing about a bit of
I do encourage everyone
to check out the review
and especially to read the book.
It's not only just a fascinating book,
but it's actually just a
beautifully written book
and a really good read.
So, I recommend it to
everyone very highly.
So please join me in
silently thanking Phil Nord
for this really enlightening
afternoon presentation.
We're really, really grateful to you.
So thank you.
- Thank you all.
Thank you for coming.
I appreciate it, I really do.
Maury, Carolyn, thank you.
- Yeah.
And please make sure
if you're not signed up for the program
for the study of antisemitism
that you go to our website
and put your name on the list
and then you'll hear about
our other great activities.
We have a couple more
lectures this semester
and we look forward to seeing you there.
So thank you all very much.